[Musique]
troisième attentat en trois jours à
paris une voiture piégée explose il y un
peu plus de deux heures devant les
bâtiments du consulat d'irak cérémonie
solennelle à la grande synagogue de
paris à la mémoire des victimes de
l'attentât de la rue des rosiers à
jérusalem l'accord entre américains et
israéliens auraient été globalement
conclu sur les conditions de départ
défense de l'ol peut retrancher à dire
ou à beyrouth-ouest des combats opposent
israéliens et palestiniens l'invité de
notre journal le ministre des affaires
étrangères tunisien propos de l'accueil
des combattants palestiniens dans les
paysages
bonsoir terrible enchaînement terrible
succession d'imagés sanglantes d'image
de destruction pour la troisième fois
depuis lundi un attentat il ya un peu
plus de deux heures a été perpétré à
paris contre des biens mais aussi contre
des personnes c'était devant le consulat
d'irak dans le 16e arrondissement
une voiture piégée a explosé il y a
plusieurs blessés 17h30 à paris dans le
16ème arrondissement une voiture piégée
vient d'exploser au milieu de la rue du
général à perd face au consulat d'irak à
paris immédiatement après un autre
véhicule explose à son tour et le feu se
propage alors très rapidement dans les
immeubles situés de part et d'autre de
la rue
moins d'une heure plus tard les silver
pompiers parisiens maîtrisent l'incendié
tandis que les services du déminage
alerté eux aussi étudier une troisième
voiture sur spectre et d'être elle aussi
piégé la fumée noire qui se dégage des
immeubles rend difficile le sauvetage
des victimes
il s'agit des quatre employés de
l'ambassade d'irak blessés légèrement
par l'explosion de l'une des voitures
qui compte ne semble t-il
les bouteilles de gaz un bilan que nous
confirme l'un des responsables du corps
des sapeurs-pompiers intervenus
immédiatement sur le terrain comme ces
images le montrent
[Musique]
peu après dans les deux immeubles qui
était de part et d'autre de la voiture
qui a explosé quand nous sommes arrivés
effectivement il y avait trois étages en
flammes de à droite à gauche
finalement le feu a été rapidement
éteint et il ya en fait très peu de
public le 31 juillet 1978
l'ambassade d'irak avait déjà été
victime d'un attentat avec prise d'otage
un inspecteur ils y avaient trouvé la
mort
[Musique]
l'autre attentat c'était cette nuit
contre l'immeuble abritant une société
israélienne dans le 8e arrondissement
une passante a été blessée d'attentât
était presque revendiquée par un texte
écrit sur les murs proches textes signés
action directe
le commentaire de cette news il est 0 h
50 à paris dans le 8ème arrondissement
quand une charge explosive placée sur le
rebord d'une fenêtre ou 20 rue de la
boum éclater la seule victime une femme
de 39 ans qui promenait son chien est
blessé à la tête et aux jambes dans
l'immeuble visé au sixième étage sont
installés les bureaux d'une société
israélienne de marketing
aucun témoin personne n'a rien vu
mais les services de police découvre
sous le porche du numéro 8 de cette même
rue une inscription encore fraîche
retrait immédiat et inconditionnel des
fascistes israélien si les palestiniens
sont chassés de beyrouth
nous tuerons les financiers et les
propagandistes du sionisme signés action
directe
trois attentats trois cibles très peu vu
très politique pour beaucoup cela
apparaît comme une tentative de
déstabilisation du régime politique
français alors marcel trillât y at il un
lien entre ces trois attentats
difficile à dire claude il est en tout
cas un lien évident c'est que ces trois
attentats se sont déroulées à paris et
surtout qu'ils semblent tous avoir comme
arrière-plan les événements du
moyen-orient
deux éléments importants jamais les
chances d'aboutir à un règlement au
liban n'ont été aussi grande
d'autre part la france est l'un des pays
en prix et en prix la plus grande part
dans la recherche d'une solution
négociée
enfin il faut noter que 15 autres pays
européens a été le théâtre d'actes de
violence du même genre c'est l'autriche
autres pays 'aaa' gouvernement
socialiste ayant des liens étroits avec
l'ol paie est favorable à une solution
négociée faisant la part des droits du
peuple palestinien alors en ce qui
concerne l'attentât de cet après midi
contre l'ambassade d'irak en peut se
demander si ce pays a été visé parce
qu'il est l'un des sept pays arabes et
est en prêt à accueillir les combattants
de l'ol paie ou parce qu'il est en
guerre contre l'iran la question
obsédante qui se pose à chaque fois
tient en un mot qui qui se cache
derrière les tueurs alors plus
précisément sur l'attentât de la rue des
rosiers où on l enquête de police c'est
ce que les enquêteurs sont parvenus à
savoir un petit peu plus sur les
meurtriers
oui un peu plus claude le signalement
des tueurs de la rue des rosiers safin
en tout cas pour l'un de ces tueurs 1 m
75 brun aux cheveux ondulés carrure
athlétique pour les autres on est encore
dans le flou vous noterez que j'évite
les autres en effet il y a deux quasi
certitude maintenant ils étaient plus de
2 d'autre part il était bien accompagné
semble en tout cas de la fameuse voiture
blanche
la piste abou nidal rendu public de
manière un peu abrupte il faut bien le
dire par gaston defferre semble bien
être prise au sérieux par les enquêteurs
puisque les policiers français des
policiers français ont été envoyés en
mission à londres et à vienne en
autriche pour vérifier les éléments qui
relie les attentes re les attentats
contre l'ambassadeur d'israël en grande
bretagne et contre la grande synagogue
de vienne et celui de la rue des rosiers
en dehors de ces vérifications l'
enquête sur le carnage de la rue des
rosiers s'internationalise ses auteurs
ont sans doute pu quitter le territoire
français c'est du moins ce que pensent
les enquêteurs
peut-être vers l'italie peut-être vers
l'espagne on ne sait mais les
imbrications qui existe entre les
groupes terroristes dépasse largement
nos frontières des frontières que
certains policiers n'hésitent pas à
considérer comme un peu trop fragile
faute de moyens c'est du moins ce que
suggère cet entretien accordé à denise
boere par un peu livré ce qu'elles sont
mais précise qu'il travaille
actuellement sur le terrorisme
nous sommes différents services il y
alla de la dst il ya les renseignements
généraux il se divise en deux parties
d'ailleurs la direction centrale et en
ce qui concerne paris les rgpp
il y à la sixième section là-dessus dpj
également au ministère la police
de l'air et des frontières et à ce qu'il
concerne paris pour la police judiciaire
la brigade criminelle
quelle est la technique employée par les
terroristes pour pénétrer sur le
territoire français la plupart du temps
nous arrive sur le territoire avec de
vrais faux papiers et parfois même avec
plusieurs jeux de vrais faux papiers
d'après votre ministre gaston defferre
il est question d'une redéfinition du
droit d'asile à votre avis la france
n'est-elle pas trop hospitalière je ne
pense pas que le lieu uniquement que le
droit d'asile
il ya également la libre circulation des
personnes qui résulte des conventions
passées entre divers pays si de plus en
plus d'étrangers circulent sur le
territoire français avec des vrais faux
papiers et risque pour nous se trouvent
augmentés en et puis dans le sens pital
mans sécurité en france
là cela résulte effectivement de la
libre circulation et en définitive i20
démocratie comporte certains risques
c'est que la permet d'ailleurs de
pénétrer aussi facilement chez nous à la
mémoire des victimes des morts et des
blessés
l'une des personnes blessées l'une des
22 personnes blessées est dans un état
très grave dit encore des médecins
aujourd'hui à la mémoire des victimes de
la rue des rosiers une cérémonie
solennelle à la grande synagogue paris a
été célébrée à 18 heures une cérémonie
en présence de très nombreuses
personnalités politiques de toutes
tendances en présence de monseigneur
lustiger également le premier ministre
assistaient à l'office
le commentaire de dominique torrès
[Musique]
des prières des chants une grande
émotion la cérémonie religieuse célébrée
à la mémoire des six victimes de
l'attentât de la rue des rosiers a eu
lieu en fin d'après-midi à la synagogue
de la rue de la doue soir à paris près
de 800 personnes ont assisté à l'office
dans un grand recueillement en présence
de rené sirat le grand rabbin pierre
mauroy pour mon ministre et robert
badinter ministre de la justice
représentait le gouvernement
jacques chirac maire de paris étaient
également présents on reconnaissait
aussi au premier rang la dame simone
veil ancien président du parlement
européen
monseigneur lustiger archevêque de paris
marcel debarge de secrétaire national du
parti socialiste bernard pons secrétaire
général du rpr
michel d'ornano dépôt des fichiers pdf
du calvados légère bousculade à la
sortie de la cérémonie
au moment où pierre mauroy et robert
badinter quittait la synagogue
quelques jeunes gens les ont accueillis
aux cris de comics dehors
quant à jacques chirac il a été
légèrement applaudi on nous avait promis
des résultats rapides
après copernic en octobre 1980
malheureusement il n'y a rien cette
déclaration a été faite par le grand
rabbin monsieur rené samuel sirat de
retour en france aujourd'hui monsieur
grand ravin sirat estime cependant qu'il
n'y a pas de problème d'antisémitisme en
france et il regrette les cris hostiles
qui ont accueilli le président françois
mitterrand lundi rue des rosiers nous
avions particulièrement apprécié en
septembre 1980 la présence de monsieur
françois mitterrand à la synagogue de la
rue copernic le lendemain matin
immédiatement après l'attentât
nous avons particulièrement apprécié la
présence à la synagogue de la rue pavée
lundi soir immédiatement après
l'attentât de la rue des rosiers les
présidents de la république et du
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
et de la décentralisation et j'aurai
l'occasion de dire tout à l'heure une
combien je regrette les écrits et qui
ont été proférées à la sortie que ces
personnalités d'autres personnalités qui
étaient là de la tour des signaux à
l'office série synagogue de l'article d
alors il y avait donc de ce côté-là
reconnu être parfaitement clair quant à
la mise en cause des journalistes fait
hier sous le choc de l'émotion
le grand rabbin explique que nous sommes
dans un pays vivre le journaliste n'a de
compte à rendre qu'à sa conscience et
par conséquent sa responsabilité était
extrêmement grande bien entendu parce
que étant donné l'impact des images des
mots des textes écrits il y a lieu de
d'être particulièrement vigilants et de
veiller à au maximum d'objectivité car
l'objectivité absolue nous savons vous
et moi que ça n'existe pas
une seconde manifestation en hommage aux
victimes de l'attentât de la rue des
rosiers se déroule en ce moment même
devant le mémorial des martyrs juifs à
paris dans le 4e arrondissement
c'est une veillée qui doit se prolonger
jusqu'à minuit plusieurs personnalités
de mouvement ou d'institutions juives
doivent y prendre la parole alors sur
place en direct le compte-rendu
d'isabelle bechler
ou laisser filtrer par un service
d'ordre tout à fait impressionnant dans
les rues avoisinantes que plusieurs
centaines de personnes sont déjà venues
se recueillir au mémorial du martyr juif
inconnue c'est toute une veillée qui est
prévue ce soir jusqu'à minuit d'abord
devant le mémorial puis dans la crypte
même une longue veillée à la mémoire des
six morts et aussi en hommage aux autres
victimes de l'attentât antisémite de la
rue des rosiers
avant la prière ce sont cinq
personnalités juives qui prendront la
parole il s'agit du président du conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
france le crif monsieur alain drôle de
rothschild du grand rabbin de france
rené samuel sirat du président du
mouvement du renouveau juif m hadj
enberg du président également de la
section française du congrès juif
mondial michel dreyfus schmidt ainsi que
de l'écrivain claude mais dans la foule
très nombreuse rue rejeu froid la nier
les partis politiques également ont tenu
à participer à cette veillée sans
représenter une délégation du
secrétariat général du parti socialiste
le rpr en la personne de jacques chirac
ainsi que l'udf le représentant du parti
communiste sont pour leur part assisté à
la cérémonie de la synagogue de la rue
de la victoire mais pour l'instant rue
geoffroy-l'asnier la cérémonie n'a pas
encore commencé merci isabelle la france
condamne l'attentât contre le consulat
irakien à paris c'est un représentant du
ministère des relations extérieures qui
s'est rendu il ya quelques minutes sur
les lieux de cet attentat
donc c'est devant le consulat de
l'ambassade et l'ambassade d'irak six
représentants du ministère des relations
extérieures a exprimé sa sympathie aux
personnes blessées
le premier ministre français s'est
refusé à tout commentaire après la
déclaration de monsieur menahem begin
rendant le gouvernement et les médias
français implicitement responsables de
l'attentât
monsieur claude cheysson a cependant dit
qu'il comprenait que le premier ministre
isralien soit particulièrement affecté
que sous le coup de l'émotion
il est tenu des propos excessifs nous le
regrettons
je citais monsieur chez cents à
jérusalem c'est peut-être l'annoncent
d'une paix prochaine après la décision
du gouvernement de monsieur begin de
globalement accepté le plan de
l'émissaire américain monsieur philippe
habib
ce dernier est retourné à beyrouth avec
quelques conditions supplémentaires
posés par les y sera
dire de jérusalem pour antenne 2
jean-marc il ose l'accord d'évacuation
des palestiniens de beyrouth ouest est
pratiquement complet c'est la seule
information qui a filtré aujourd'hui de
la double série d'entretiens qui a eu
lieu à jérusalem monsieur philippe rabit
bleus médiateur américain
entretien avec le premier ministre belge
in le ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur shamir et bien sûr le général
sharon ministre de la défense
ultimes tractations qui n'ont donné lieu
à aucun commentaire officiel en israël
des tractations qui ont sans doute porté
sur le calendrier de l'arrivée de la
force internationale d'interposition à
beyrouth
les israëliens semble-t-il reste opposé
à ce que les préparatifs de la première
évacuation soit confiée à un premier
groupe issu du contingent français
il préférerait voir la tâche confiée à
l'armée libanaise
enfin on s'entendra peut-être sur le
fait que ce soit les italiens qui
finalement arrivés les premiers
vous le voyez des problèmes bien mineure
maintenant que l'on sait que sept pays
arabes et surtout la syrie sont préparés
t-il à accueillir formellement les
palestiniens de beyrouth
c'était un obstacle majeur tel qu'on
voyait ici à jérusalem et que l'on dit
maintenant lever autant dire qu on
fignole ici un accord à coups de
garanties diplomatiques sans négliger à
aucun moment la pression militaire qui
reste très importante autour de beyrouth
et dans la vallée de la bekaa monsieur
habib quant à lui est reparti pour
beyrouth on l'attend peut-être dès
demain de nouveau à jérusalem avec dans
sa poche peut-être cette fois-ci un
accord final malgré tout malgré
peut-être cette paix prochaine la guerre
continue au liban des combats à la
roquette et au mortier et à l'armé
légère ont opposé cet après midi les
forces israéliennes et palestiniennes à
beyrouth ouest
tout cela après 24 heures de
bombardements en somme une journée comme
les autres pour les habitants de
beyrouth
le récit de philippe gassot l'envoyé
spécial d'antenne 2 au liban le fait que
la capitale et dans mon verre brindille
le plan de table négociateur américain
n'a pas véritablement impressionné les
habitants de beyrouth web qui ont en ce
moment votre préoccupation
on pourrait dire qu'il va se passer bien
particulier de ce côté d'importants tirs
d'artillerie sur les corniches a dit la
banque genevoise
avoue-t-il il y avait encore là bas dit
il il n'a quoi sourire 10h01 aubry venue
frapper un appartement en plein centre
du quartier way samedi l'aviation
israélienne par dizaines de vagues à
écraser encore un peu plus ces camps au
suspens précieuse nouvelle action
ponctuée par des rares tirs de désir
pour nous ici la journée les patios
vitesse elle peut encore réserver des
surprises pour les auditeurs audoise
cette journée et en aucun cas
particulière alors les discussions
politiques médina bible en bleu située
en dehors de la réalité qui pourrait
croire en cette violence ces déchets
chaque jour une solution est proche et
que le canon le cera de masse en
attendant les abris et on verra bien si
les américains les français les italiens
vont décider abbey road où on est
seulement certain d'une chose c'est que
demain ce sont encore les op ils vont
arriver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la tunisie a fait savoir qu'elle était
prête à accueillir le premier contingent
de combattants palestiniens qui tend
beyrouth combattants qualifié par les
autorités tunisiennes de valeureux
frères palestiniens en direct avec nous
ce soir dans notre journal monsieur le
ministre affaires étrangères monsieur
caïd essebsi bonsoir monsieur le
ministre merci de bien vouloir répondre
à notre question elle sera très générale
pour commencer pourquoi accueillir ces
combattants palestiniens sur sol
tunisien
la tunisie a décidé d'accueillir un
contingent des résistants palestiniens
établit actuellement à beyrouth à la
demande de l'organisation de libération
de la palestine et de monsieur yasser
arafat
pourquoi le président bourguiba a donné
son accord
c'est précisément pour bien démontrer
que la tunisie toujours été aux côtés
des causes justes et des peuples qui
luttent pour leur dignité leur liberté
je m'unis sont dans l'impression que
tout cela vient quand même un peu tard
et que l'ensemble des pays arabes n'ont
pas véritablement répondu au début de
l'activité israélienne au liban aux
appels de yasser arafat c'est quand même
assez étonnant qu'au bout de deux mois
de guerre
il n'y a pas encore eu de sommet arabe
pour le
d'abord la tunisie a été sollicité pour
la première fois arrière et dix minutes
après les avoir été sollicité le
président bourguiba a répondu
favorablement à la demande de l'ol tu es
si d'autres pays arabes
on met plus de temps faut leur poser la
question c'est combien de combattants
palestiniens à l'est vous accueillir
et quand vont-ils arriver est-ce que
c'est créer un chiffre mais je pense que
la tunisie accueillera plusieurs
centaines de palestiniens
quand nous avons actuellement des
discussions en cours pour déterminer les
fixer les modalités de transfert et
d'accueil
mais je pense que très prochainement las
une question de jours ou de semaines
qu'ils ont peut-être la semaine
prochaine et vous souhaitez monsieur le
ministre que les combattants
palestiniens qui seront donc en tunisie
puisse retourner rapidement en palestine
pour y fonder un état souverain alors
qu'est ce que cela signifie pour vous y
at il un calendrier il ya t'il modalités
précises d'abord c'est pas moi qui le
souhaitent seulement c'est la nature du
combat de ces palestiniens qui ont pris
les armes pour précisément une cause
juste qui est la leur ils veulent
légitimement aspirer à la liberté la
dignité et espérer la constitution d'un
état sur la terre de leurs ancêtres et
je pense que le lieu indiqué c'est la
palestine pour la construction d'un tel
état est-ce que vous pensez que ce
départ de beyrouth va faciliter dans les
prochaines années ou peut-être même dans
les prochains mois des négociations avec
les américains je pense que les
américains actuellement ont une vision
plus claire de la réalité du combat
palestinien
tout le monde sait que
l'amérique a été et pendant très
longtemps intoxiqués par la propagande
sioniste et qu'effectivement nous sommes
aperçus que il n'avait pas à une
connaissance suffisante de la nature de
ceux des problèmes je pense
qu'actuellement ils ont fait l'effort
pour comprendre et je pense qu'ils ont
une meilleure vision des choses alors
que vous allez aujourd'hui accueillir
ces combattants palestiniens
vous êtes au courant évidemment de
l'attentât qui a eu lieu à paris rue des
rosiers
quelles réactions avez vous à ce propos
en tout cas en tunisie nous avons
toujours condamner ce genre d'attentât
qui contre des innocents et nous pensons
que c'est effectivement un attentat
odieux mais je voudrais pas tout de même
qu'on se serve de l'émotion légitime qui
est soulevée par un tel attentat pour
masquer la réalité
israël y est né pendant plusieurs mois
le peuple libanais le peuple palestinien
est en train de subir les bombardements
inhumain les morts de femmes d'enfants
et je pense que aussi ça doit soulever
notre légitime indignation
il y à d'autres pays zara bernard
benyamin qui ont donc décidé
d'accueillir les combattants
palestiniens est ce qu'on peut déjà
dresser une carte
oui vous savez qu'ils sont au nombre de
7 dans la mesure où l'egypte est
extrêmement réticente le kern accepte
d'accueillir les palestiniens comme dans
le cadre d'un règlement global du
problème
alors nous avons donc outre la tunisie
dont vous donnons nous venons d'entendre
le ministre des affaires étrangères nous
avons donc la syrie qui accepteraient
4600 palestiniens dont 2000 appartenant
à des organisations minoritaires de l'ol
paie la jordanie elle est d'accord pour
en recevoir un millier à condition
toutefois qu'ils soient porteurs de
passeports jordanien
le soudan est disposé à en recevoir 600
les deux yémen nord-yémen sud yémen sont
d'accord sur le principe mais n'ont pas
précisé le nombre des palestiniens
qu'ils accepteraient enfin l'irak l'ira
qui se déclarent prêts à recevoir tous
les palestiniens qu'il n'aurait pas
trouvé de pays d'accueil
alors est-ce qu'on ne peut pas comme
nous refaire remarquer à tous ces pays
arabes que ça vient peut-être un petit
peu tard pour les combattants
palestiniens
oui vous savez claude il se trouve que
depuis trente ans les pays arabes
portent à bout de bras si j'ose dire la
question palestinienne qu à cause d'un
certain nombre de problèmes sont nés sur
le plan intérieur dans beaucoup de pays
arabes et qu'à terme cette question
palestinienne a toujours entraîné des
conflits sanglants la jordanie hier la
syrie en 1976 et le liban aujourd'hui en
savent bigrement quelque chose pour
toutes ces raisons les pays arabes n'ont
pas bougé depuis deux mois depuis le
début de la guerre au liban
car même s'ils ont du mal à se l'avouer
eux mêmes et on a vu tout à l'heure la
réaction du ministre tunisien des
affaires étrangères
d'une certaine manière ils ont estimé
que le problème palestinien ne valait
pas le risque d'un affrontement direct
avec israël
voilà donc pour le silence qui a
provoqué ont sans doute colère et
amertume côté palestinien seulement à
partir du moment où israël est sur le
point de signer le plan de paix de
philippe abîme les pays arabes pouvaient
difficilement rester muet d'autant que
l'arabie saoudite et les américains pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux ont exercé
des pressions très fortes pour qu'ils
accueillent les palestiniens mettant
ainsi un terme à la guerre au liban
merci bien dans les 10 pays de la
communauté européenne demandent ensemble
officiellement aux états unis de revenir
sur leur décision étendant aux firmes
européennes
l'embargo sur les matériels destinés aux
gazoducs euros sibérie la décision
commune des européens s'appuie sur un
dossier juridique tendant à prouver que
la décision américaine est contraire au
droit international
le dollar le dollar était au dessus de 7
francs lundi les temps il était en
dessous de 7 francs mardi
il est remonté au-dessus de cette fois
aujourd'hui 7 francs 0 2 très exactement
sur le marché des changes à pâques
enfin en italie monsieur spadolini
remplace monsieur spadolini plus
exactement après la démission de son
gouvernement
monsieur spadolini est à nouveau chargé
de former le nouveau gouvernement
un retour à la case départ apparemment
bien difficile compte tenu de la
nécessité de multiples alliances entre
les partis politiques d'italie pour la
cinquième fois depuis 1976 un condamné à
mort et exécuté aux états unis c'était
dans l'état de virginie
cet homme franck coppola âgé de 38 ans
avait été condamné pour le meurtre d'une
femme
il ne voulait pas terminer sa vie en
prison il avait renvoyé ses avocats
ceux-ci ont tenté jusqu'au bout
juridiquement d'empêcher la chaise
électrique de fonctionner en vain il y à
plus d'un millier de condamnés à mort
dans les prisons américaines
la peine capitale fut réintroduite par
la législation d'une quarantaine dans la
législation d'une quarantaine d'états il
y a maintenant six ans c'était en 1976
se tient du western biblique et de la
bande dessinée c'est de l'anticipation
avec des bons et des méchants cela
s'appelle mad max 2 est un film où l'on
n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens ni sur la
représentation de la violence
george miller le metteur en scène
australien ce film qui obtint le grand
prix du festival d'avoriaz lé grand prix
du film fantastique il ya quelques mois
est allé très loin dans la démonstration
pour lui il serait naïf de se voiler la
face et d'occulter toutes les images de
violence qui font l'actualité
quotidienne
regardez
[Musique]
mezouar a fait hier soir les pardons
hier soir les footballeurs des équipes
de première division ont joué le premier
match de championnat de france on aura
surtout noté la victoire de bordeaux
face à monaco et la défaite de
saint-etienne à bastia mais il faut
également saluer le bon comportement des
équipes nouvellement promu en première
division et notamment l'équipe de
mulhouse et surtout celle de toulouse
grande première pour mulhouse tout
d'abord qui rencontrait les canaris
donnant un grand pour ses débuts en
première division
les mulhousiens ont fait mieux que
résister hier soir après avoir répliqué
aux bus du nanterre rio grâce à cette
tête de vercel leur capitaine sur ce
corner d'assad
l'international algérien ils ont même
failli prendre l'aventage sur ce but
refusé par monsieur d'aylmer à ouattara
pour un hors jeu tout à fait discutable
1-1 donc un score logique devant des
nantais déjà en forme toulouse
maintenant qu'ils rencontrent et
strasbourg avec ses vedettes du mondial
le pet et solaire un but de ferradj qui
permet aux toulousains d'ouvrir le score
réaction des strasbourgeois presque
immédiate avec ce but de gentes après un
petit exploit technique et enfin le plus
beau but du match par le meilleur joueur
sur le terrain le toulousain que sa peau
toulouse et mulhouse de nouveau très
prometteur un patron de la cia
hier soir paris saint germain lui n'a
pas vraiment convaincu ses supporters
malgré sa courte victoire devant rouen
mais le paris saint germain sera
renforcé pour son prochain match puisque
le néerlandais kyste qui vient du club
az 67 en effet signé un contrat
aujourd'hui de trois ans pour le paris
saint-germain contrat permanent avec
monsieur météo gillot pétré
oui mais je pars bientôt en vacances je
vous préviens tout de suite demain ce
sera le jour le plus chaud depuis le
début du mois d'août mais pas le plus
chaud depuis le début de l'été regardez
la photo satellite
elle est étonnante regardez bien voici
la quasi totalité de l'europe
occidentale et de l'afrique du nord
aussi dégager de nuages c'est tout juste
si l'on voit ici quelques altocumulus
dans la région de nice est ici quelques
stratocumulus mais vraiment il faut
avoir de bons yeux partout ailleurs donc
c'est du très très grand beau temps
cette année anticyclone l'ennui c'est
que l'anticyclone va se déplacer vers
l'est et que ce très mauvais temps là
dont voici une ligne nuageuse va
progressivement pénétré très lentement
comme ceux ci sur la france
on retrouve cela sur notre carte pour
demain voici la carte donc pour demain
c'est du grand beau temps beaucoup
énormément de soleil après dissipation
de quelques petite brume matinale mais
qui se dissiperont très vite sur le
centre et le bassin parisien
et puis en cours de journée on verra
arriver quelques nuages on verra arriver
des nuages sur les côtes de la manche et
de l'atlantique qui pourraient donner en
fin de journée des orages isolés
les températures prévues par la météo
nationale pour demain sont en hausse
minimum 24 degrés à cherbourg et brest
et minimum 1 24 maximum 35 degrés à
perpignan nîmes et marseille
j'ai fait la moyenne de tout ce qui
reste ça donne pour la france 31 degrés
de moyenne
globalement sur tout le pays demain
c'est le jeudi 2 ou 3 minutes de soleil
en moins levé 6h40 coucher 21h11 c'est
le dernier quartier de lune si vous vous
levez peu avant le lever du soleil vous
avez une force de voir des pluies
d'étoilés filantes on a beaucoup en ce
moment et c'est ciplic
enfin c'est la salle clarisse merci elle
après les prévisions
les pronostics ce du grand handicap de
la manche kart et deauville demain voici
les pronostics de tir m brasse vous les
voyez saint cyr sur votre écran le 13 le
24 le 7 le 1/10 septe le 2 le 19 et le
et puis voici les résultats du tirage du
loto qui viennent de nous parvenir
le 16 le 31 le 32 le 35 44
le 47 e vous avez le temps de noter
ainsi que le numéro complémentaire qui
est le 19
voilà je vous rappelle le dernier titre
de ce journal puisque la formation de
l'est pas revenue en fin d'après midi un
troisième attentat à paris devant le
consulat du rac qui lie à plusieurs
personnes blessées
et c'est un mouvement d'opposition
chiite irakien qui vient de revendiquer
cet attentat la dernière édition de
notre journal se sera 23h25 vous y
retrouverez jean-louis lawson pour la
perche vous retrouverez demain à 20
heures
bonsoir merci
[Musique]